[Music]
hi i'm ken schatz i'm a professor of
political economy at the stanford gsb my
name is neil malhotra i'm also a
professor of political economy at the
stanford gsb and ken and i would like to
share some key class takeaways from the
course we teach leading with values
which is also the title of our
forthcoming book
[Music]
when people disagree about ethical
issues in the workplace or in their
organizations sometimes these
disagreements are about facts and
sometimes they're about values now when
we disagree over facts these are not
easy things to resolve but they can be
addressed if people can bring evidence
to the table this is not the case with
values no amount of evidence is going to
convince people that their values are
right or wrong
so where do these values come from well
psychologists have shown that they come
from deep-seated moral intuitions that
lie in our gut and they often have a
cultural basis
what does this mean for leading with
values well when people disagree about
ethical issues in the workplace it's not
because some people are moral and some
are immoral it's that they're bringing
different core values based
considerations to the table
people around you specifically those who
are critical of you and your company
oftentimes are motivated by key moral
intuitions so it's not helpful to just
dismiss their concerns out of hand by
saying that they're self-interested or
motivated by money it's oftentimes
important to respect the fact that they
have moral intuitions even if they're
different from your own
we like to oftentimes think of ourselves
as very rational and everybody else is
driven by emotion but this isn't the
case
even when we're making very rigorous
highly structured analytical arguments
the roots of those arguments are in our
gut intuitions and that self-awareness
is important to be reflective and to be
skeptical of yourself
[Music]
if you want to communicate with others
persuade them and manage disagreements
in your organization it's oftentimes
important not to use your own moral
intuitions at the basis of framing your
argument but to be empathetic and to see
what are other people's moral intuitions
and construct your arguments about how
they see the world not necessarily just
how you see the world
our students talk a lot about their
sense of purpose and their personal
values and their personal ethical
commitments
we also see leaders of companies talking
about how they want all of their
employees to do the right thing and to
behave in ways that are aligned with the
company's values
and in a societal level we see many
companies especially nowadays talking
about their commitments to improving
society in a whole lot of different ways
all of these good intentions are
wonderful
however
as wonderful as good intentions are
good institutions are even better
so what do we mean by good institutions
we mean setting up incentives rules and
norms that promote good behavior
so this is most obvious within a company
when a leader of a company says you know
we expect our employees to do the right
thing here's our values as a company
that's good intentions
good institutions is setting up
incentives and rules and norms within
the company so that people are rewarded
for doing things that are in line with
that good behavior and are not rewarded
for doing things that are out of step
with those values
and if we want companies to do the right
thing for society when push comes to
shove we need to have government
regulations rules and laws that
incentivize companies to do those things
that are good for society rather than
giving them perverse incentives to do
things that might be bad for society
that
set of government rules laws and
institutions that's really what's
crucial for unleashing the amazingly
productive and innovative capacities of
capitalism in ways that are good for
society as a whole
[Music]
i have a 13 year old daughter and i
think she's entirely unimpressed so i
think from her perspective i don't know
anything about anything i think my
daughter and my parents would have the
same reaction which is my wife is the
real scientist and i'm
[Music]
you